talk about um the original bass player
that died in the band actually it's 10
years ago um in about four weeks you
guys were in the bus fighting over who
gets to sit in the front of the bus
do i have that right ish it was um this
is one of the kirk him and kirk were
drawing stars about who was going to
sleep in a specific bunk and cliff
pulled the longest dawn went in that
bunk
and when the bus i mean that was
supposed to be the good bunk yeah that
was supposed to be the good bunker and
um we were driving from stockholm to
copenhagen and we were all asleep in the
bus and all of a sudden we hit a patch
of ice and the whole bus just started
flipping over
everybody else walked out and it's just
like where's cliff
though he's probably still in there
sleeping now it's the kind of guy who
was you could sleep through anything and
he's still in there sleeping so we all
went to the hospital and got treated for
you know broken toes and all this type
of stuff and the guy comes in and says
your bass player's dead oh man i was
like pretty heavy that was 86 10 years
ago so that was like before you got
really big in fact it was on master
puppets it was right after we came off
the aussie tour so it was kind of when
we were still getting it together you
were really tight with the guy right
yeah we lived with him every day for
four or five years did the band almost
break up
no the only thing we had to do at the
time was just battle on you know we'd
always been about fighting against
everything that came our way and stuff
like that and that really sucks because
think of the life you would have had if
you just you know lived yeah you never
got to see the big success you would
have been digging it man that's kind of
freaky though for her yeah the guy who
didn't get the bunk the first time i
heard that story right was when kirk
told it to mtv so we're sitting watching
mtv a couple years ago when they've done
a special on us and it was just like he
told that story for the first time i got
kind of misty-eyed they never told it to
me it was pretty heavy
you